うわすげえメッチャ効く
こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
なんかアダルト商品と勘違いしてる人が多いと思うんですけども
これは本来マッサージ器具なので
エロくありません
ご安心ください
というわけでようやくエンディング動画も終わり
夏休みもいよいよ後半に近づいて参りました
そろそろやってもいいのではないでしょうか
質問コーナー募集ーーーー！！
はい、というわけで質問コーナーの質問、リクエストを募集しようと思います
まあ、いつもやってるんですけども
コメントとか質問をひとまとめにするために
この動画の！
この動画のコメント欄に
質問
リクエスト
言いたい事
暴言
なんでもいいので自由に書いてくださいませ
あの~すごい「質問コーナーまだですか？」っていうリクエストが多かったです
本当にありがとうございます
やっぱり僕の中でED動画を終わらないと
やっぱり他の事に手を付けちゃダメだなって思ってたので
質問コーナーしばらくやってこなかったんですけども
せっかく夏ですし
夏の最後くらい質問コーナーでバシッとしめようと思いまして
8月中には質問コーナーしようと思っております
わかったら皆さんこの動画だよ
この動画です
この動画のコメント欄に書いてください
あ、今書くタイムだよ
皆さん今動画のコメント欄に是非コメントしてください
なんなんだろう、質問コーナーがもうなんか
はじめしゃちょーの最強必殺武器動画みたいになっちゃってるんで
ハードル上がりすぎても怖いな
あぁ＾～シンプルに気持ちいい
8月の27日
8月の27日までこのコメント欄でコメント待っております
多分なんですけど8月中には質問コーナー動画出すと思うので
是非皆さんお楽しみにしてくださいませ
皆さんの面白い
面白くなくてもいい!!
もう悲しくてもいいです
もうなんでもいいので皆さんのコメントお待ちしておりますでございます
モザイクかけたらすごい...あれだよね...
うぇへっへ
是非皆さんの熱いコメントお待ちしております
ホントにね質問コーナー募集動画ほど
何もすることがない動画はないから
俺は自由にしてるよ
今のうちにコメント書いちゃっていいよ
本当は今日は電マを上から吊るそうと思ってたんですよ
こうやれば吊るせるんですけど
吊るしたらすごいよね
頭のマッサージとかできそうだよね
うおおうわあやばいやあび
待って、すごい
のう、脳波が
おおおお
痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い
痛い痛い痛い
待って、本当にやばい
あ～でもこれすげーな超便利だな
おわあこれ効くな
итвщшыргшвауцшгуквышмршаогшк
¡Hola!  ¿Te gusta el Hajime?
あ＾～いてて
はいというわけで皆さん是非コメントお待ちしております
というわけで期間は申しましたので
この日までに是非皆さんコメントしてください
そして8月中にはやろうと思っております
先に言っときましょう
遅れたらごめんなさい
じゃあな
待ってるよ
( ^)o(^ )
('ω')ノ
(*ﾉωﾉ)
ででででん